so this right over here is a screenshot
of the describing subsets of sample
spaces exercise on Khan Academy and I
thought I would do a couple of examples
just because it's good practice just
thinking about how do we describe sets
and subsets so it reads Harry Potter is
at Ollivanders wand shop as we all know
the wand must choose the wizard so Harry
cannot make the choice himself he
interprets the wand selection as a
random process so he can compare the
probabilities of different outcomes the
wood types available are Holly Elm maple
and wenge winged whinge the core
materials on offer are phoenix feather
unicorn hair dragon scale raven feather
and thestral tail alright
based on the sample space of possible
outcomes listed below what is more
likely and so we see here we have four
different types of woods for the wand
and then each of those could be combined
with five different types of core
phoenix feather unicorn hair dragon
scale raven feather and thestral tail
and so that gives us four different
woods and each of those can be combined
for five different cores 20 possible
outcomes and they don't say it here but
the way they're talking I guess we can
I'm gonna go with the assumption that
they're equally likely outcomes although
it would have been nice if they said
that these are all equally equally
likely but these are the 20 outcomes and
so which of these are more likely the
one that selects Harry will be made of
holly or unicorn hair so how many of
those outcomes involve this so if Holly
are these five outcomes and if you said
Holly or unicorn hair it's gonna be
these five outcomes plus well this one
involves unicorn hair but we've already
we've already included this one but the
other ones that's not included for the
holly that involved unicorn here are the
elm unicorn the maple unicorn and the
winds unicorn so it's these five plus
these three right over here so eight of
these 20 outcomes and if these are all
equally likely outcomes that means
there's an eight twenty it's probability
of a wand that it will be made of Holly
or unicorn hair so this is eight twenty
eight so that's the same thing as four
10s or 40% chance now
the one that selects Harry will be made
of holly and unicorn hair well Holly and
unicorn hair that's only one out of the
20 outcomes so this of course is going
to be a higher probability it actually
includes this outcome and then seven
other outcomes so this is this the first
choice is this includes the outcome for
the second choice plus seven other
outcomes so this is definitely going to
be a higher probability let's do let's
do a couple more of these or at least
one of them one more of these you and a
friend are playing fire water sponge and
ever played that game in this game each
of the two players chooses fire water or
sponge both players reveal their choice
at the same time and the winner is
determined based on the choices I guess
this is like rock paper scissors fire
beats sponge by burning it sponge beats
water by soaking it up and water beats
fire by putting it out alright well kind
of make sense if both players choose the
same object that is a tie all the
possible outcomes of the game are listed
below if we take outcomes 1 3 4 5 7 & 8
as a subset of the sample space which of
the following statements which of the
statements below describe this subset so
let's look at the outcomes that they
have over here well it makes sense that
there are nine possible outcomes because
for each of the three choices I can make
there's going to be three choices that
the friend my friend can make so three
times three is nine
let's see they've outcome they've
highlighted these red outcomes outcome 1
3 4 5 7 & 8 so let's see what's common
about them outcome 1 fire I get fire
friend gets water okay so let's see my
friend would win outcome 3 I pick fire
my friend does sponge so actually I
would I would win that one and then
outcome for water fire and then outcome
5 water sponge sponge huh these are all
I don't see a pattern just yet let's see
the choices the subset consists of all
outcomes where your friend does not win
all outcomes where your friend does not
win well that's not true because look
outcome 1
come one my friend wins water puts out
fire so that's we're not gonna select
this first choice so let's see the
subset consists of all the outcomes
where your friend wins or there's a tie
so let's see where the friend wins or
there's a type of outcome three this is
this is one where this is an outcome
where I would win
where are you or whoever your is where
they're talking about this is one where
the friend doesn't win because fire
burns sponge so I'm not gonna select
that one either choice three the subset
consists of all of the outcome where you
win or there is a tie well we just said
outcome one I don't win that my friend
wins that water puts out puts out the
fire now it's the glass choice the
subset consists of all the outcomes
where there is not a tie alright so this
is interesting
because look outcome two there is a tie
outcome six there is a tie outcome nine
there is a tie there's actually only
three scenarios where there's a tie
either it's fire fire water water or
spun sponge and those are the ones that
are not selected so all of these someone
is going to win outcome one three four
five seven or eight so definitely
definitely go with that one